しかし日本語の文字はいつも同じ風に発音
されますというのは英語の
絵はAになったりああになったりさらにA
になったりしますよねしかし日本語のあは
いつもああですし日本語の意味もいつも
いいですなのでまぁ
綺麗な発音で話したいのであれば書く音を
クリアに言うべきですはいでは次の
例文に行きたいと思います
トーマさんお願いしますはい
大学が新しい
学生を受け入れましたいいですねただし
学生じゃなくて学生ですでも先生はアマ
ですので日本語の文字はいつも同じ風に
発音されますが
えいというペアはいつも
として発音されますこれだけは
覚えてくださいねはいわかりました
大学が
新しい
学生を受け入れましたはいOKですでも
トーマスさんすいません最後の単語をもう
一度言ってください
受けれましたわかったトーマスさんは多分
綴りを間違えたと思います受けれました
じゃなくて受け入れましたですでもこの胃
は
けの後に来ていますはいそうですですから
これは
絵として発音されますあれなので受け入れ
ましたですあでも違いますこの今確かに絵
の後に来ていますが
ちょっと待ってください絶対に
覚えた方がいいのでわかった日本語の文字
は
基本的にいつも同じ風に発音されます基本
的にいつもしかし
えいというペアはいつもとして発音され
ますはいただし動詞に入っている場合はa
としてじゃなくてエイとして発音されます
これがいの発音規則です先生
規則は何ですか
ルールのことですでもトーマス
規則じゃなくて
規則です
木のいは言いませんので先生先ほどから何
を言ったわかったと日本語の「は基本的に
いつもいいとして発音されますただしそれ
が
絵として発音される場合もあれば
完全に消える場合もあって先生場合は何
ですかですよねわかった日本語の文字は
基本的に
特技いつも同じ風に発案されますが